erasmus plus will become bigger and
more intensive because it would
most likely provide more financial resources if we haven't negotiated about it
and erasmus will also become
inclusive because they make
sure that apprentices who
may not traditionally take part in such a
mobility program are
addressed here more intensively
today we had a second a
second activity prevention of
antisemitism where it became
clear that education is a very important
a very important instrument in the
fight against antisemitism the
european solidarity score it's
about young people doing social work here
for me it's always a big thing  important that
young people have the chance to get to know other
young people, other ways of
life, and if
they also do this through social commitment
, in my opinion
, it is even better and then there were the district administrator's
conclusions on the ro  lle of
youth work in the context of migration
and flight
he is fit as minister
26 pictures of tumor included
[music]